friends um
i think if you've seen my content
no doubt you're aware that i'm
interested in healing
i'm interested in the protocols and
procedures
that are able to
engage me
so that
deep adjustments can transpire i think
that we
hold trauma in the body i think we hold
ptsd in the body the body keeps the
score perhaps the greatest book about
trauma ever and i think we hold these
patterns these fear patterns in our
nervous system they are a kind of muscle
memory they hold us in place and they
kind of give us an electric shock every
time we have a creative impulse and so
we're walking on the eggshells of our
own
past experiences like pillaging our
inner life and it's a horrible thing and
the body keeps the score and we carry
this with us and i'm interested
in the protocols and procedures that
offer us
freedom from this constraint the
protocols and procedures
that offer us relief
from these constraints from these
assaults and our lived experience i'm
interested in extasis which is to move
beyond the self i'm interested in flow
where the sense of self vanishes and you
experience a sense of timelessness
instead where action and awareness merge
all of these are great and i'm privy to
experiences that have transpired when i
was there but also not there where
subject object and process became one
thing those experiences are creatively
cathartic but perhaps my greatest my
most favorite physiological
trauma release
is
laughter
a laughing fit
what do i mean
by a laughing fit friends
[Music]
well a laughing fit is an experience of
losing yourself completely uh in absurd
irresistible
hilarity
a laughing fit is a physiological
de-stressor a laughing fit is a
physiological almost orgasmic
trauma release emotion release
discharge of sorts it's a kind of
ecstatic version
of the
of the impulses captured in the film the
purge where one day per year everybody
could explode without filter
well laughter is a
is a non-destructive purge it's a
healing purge that relieves us and
releases us from energies that are
constraining us and perhaps the best
definition of laughter i found when
actually researching its cathartic role
in trauma release its physiological
transformative impact upon the lived
experience of our nervous system and the
essay was called laughter
nature's epileptoid catharsis
nature's epileptoid catharsis of course
and so think of how strong this
statement is when you hear the word
epileptoid you imagine an epileptic
seizure a shaking a kind of uh you know
speaking in tongues ecstatically before
gods like it's it's it it takes
possession of you like a kind of
exorcism and so it's an epileptoid
experience but then they also call it
cathartic right laughter is nature's
epileptoid catharsis and so what that
means is it's an experience that takes
possession of you like an epileptic
seizure and with that epileptoid
physiological discharge you're you're
experiencing emotional cleansing and
catharsis simultaneously so it's an
epileptoid catharsis let me continue
laughter is a symbolically triggered
release mechanism that unleashes
instinctive drive energies associated
with survival and in the process
lowering anxiety the use of humor to
trigger the laugh reflex has become a
cultural activity in which unacceptable
impulses are expressed in an acceptable
manner this is an example of aesthetic
distance sacred space and as this occurs
there is an emancipatory release of
repressed energies and assorted
conflicts
are resolved
all contradictions reconcile listen to
that again right so we use humor to
evoke these laughing fits to evoke this
epileptoid catharsis we use humor and
then we trigger the laugh reflex a
physiological response and this has
become then a culturally celebrated way
a socially acceptable activity in which
we can take unacceptable impulses and
express them in an acceptable manner and
here we heal because in this epileptoid
catharsis there is an emancipatory
release of repressed energies and
assorted conflicts being resolved and
that's where i talk about the discharge
it's an emancipatory release of
repressed energies and assorted
conflicts and they are resolved in
quaking annihilating glory and freedom
from self-consciousness